all right Deadpool spoiler talk you guys
have seen the movie Deadpool by now
right
yet if you haven't why are you planning
to all right cool that's right if my
time on YouTube has taught me anything
the one thing people love more than me
talking about a movies me talking about
the spoilers in the movie it's actually
not true yeah let's talk about some
Deadpool spoilers and that is a fair
spoiler warning for Deadpool if you have
not seen Deadpool I'm a dog Ramon some
spoilers here I have a spoiler free
review should go check that out
then come back here after you see the
movie and this is really funny other
superhero movies that I have reviewed
this is the least spoiler ish one pretty
cut-and-dry very straightforward it's a
simple plot guys a mercenary guy falls
in love guy gets cancer guy has a
procedure done on him cures the cancer
turns him into a super hero who wants to
kill the dick who did actually he wants
the dick to cure his face because his
face gets really messed up in the
procedure and is pretty much the gist of
it but his movie knew what it was and
played it up I wish half the movies out
there were half as self-aware as this
movie starting out the opening credits
were great they were fantastic
it let me know exactly what kind of
movie this was going to be which was a
great Deadpool movie the opening credits
are like starring some douchebag
directed by some talentless hack
starring a CGI character is just no one
actually had their names in the opening
credits it was all just parody and the
action was wrought it's really funny my
cousin was like hey would Sarah enjoy
the movie
Sarah is her little sister who's in
elementary school I was like do not take
Sarah one thing I forgot to talk about
my actual review I love how Deadpool's
eyes are expressive it makes zero sense
how he can express anything with his
eyes because his eyes are a mask when it
never explains it in the movie it just
happens because comic book is drawn that
way it just added so much more to this
movie this character something that you
couldn't do if this movie was trying to
take itself seriously as a comic book
movie luckily this movie doesn't give a
[ __ ] a colossus and negasonic teenage
warhead are there to try to stop
Deadpool because Colossus is like you
should join us you look make good x-men
right I don't want to hear how shitty my
Russian accent is right I did a pretty
solid one of my review of jack ryan
shadow recruit i think it was pretty
good but no Colossus wants him to be an
x-men he's like I don't have time for
your Boy Scout [ __ ] Colossus I feel
look at it's like Deadpool with mega the
worst x-men the worst x-man he's pretty
morally ambiguous there are a lot of
[ __ ] in this movie that are not the
Boy Scout poster children for Heroes
which is a big sigh of relief in a world
that's just overcrowded with comic-book
movies
I love comic book movies it's a bring
him on whatever I'm not bored yet but I
do like my size of reliefs my favorite
meta humour fourth wall breaking moment
was when Colossus cuffs Deadpool he was
like I'm taking you to the professor and
he was like Stewart or McAvoy this whole
alternate universe think it's really
confusing brilliant wonderful awesome
genius that is fantastic I loved that
line he's cuffed and he's like you guys
ever see 127 hours and whips out a knife
you're like oh [ __ ] he's like spoiler
alert
so it's cutting his arm away one of the
things I loved his Deadpool starting
it's not like he was an upstanding guy
and he was an alright dude and then he
got the Deadpool outfit and then he
became some [ __ ] talking Deadpool oh
really when he's in the costume he's the
same guy he was before he even had the
cancer he just he was a dick then and
he's just kind of a prick now the thing
about it is it is perfect Deadpool Ryan
Reynolds was so the perfect temple I
mean in comic book movies is usually not
someone who so completely makes the
character his it's happened a few times
Hugh Jackman as Wolverine I would call
that one Heath Ledger's Joker Robert
Downey jr. as Iron Man and Ryan Reynolds
as Deadpool
I hope it's completely career changing
for him for the better and I hope the
existence of this movie I hope this
movie get so much money that studios
have to re-evaluate the whole pg-13
things like wait a minute I mean we can
make an r-rated comic book rated R and
it's okay it'll still make money yeah
what we've been saying and his [ __ ]
talkie his Deadpool was like when he's
getting tortured he's in that hyperbaric
chamber that's suffocating him because
Daario naharis is doing it to him it was
one of those things where when he got
his face messed up he's like you're
sadistic [ __ ] and you're like oh there's
no joke coming he's just pissed
yeah his life is kind of being destroyed
right now and you get it but movies have
to do that it's like oh yeah a jokey
jokey side now it's time to get real
it's one of the complements of this
movie knew every line to ride it knew
when to be kind of serious and knew when
to be jokey knew one to be meta it knew
how to be Deadpool gonna admit I was
remarkably attracted to negasonic
teenage warhead I would be honest with
ya I know
Inara from Firefly was in this movie and
I walked out going negasonic teenage
warhead nice it's okay she's 19 so it's
not creepy or weird it's a little weird
that I looked up her age but it's okay
because it's legal creepy and weird no
seriously she was super cute super cool
and she turned into fire energy and blue
shut up she answers the door at the
mansion and Deadpool's the
and he's like Ripley from alien 3 I was
like yeah totally Ripley from alien 3
she's like [ __ ] your old I was like
Emily I that's what I was said and I
can't speak enough about the action in
the fights the fights were really
exciting to fight at the end was really
gratifying it was just a solid hand hand
sword - sword will sword - axe fight and
at the end he gets mr. dick bag and then
he's gonna kill him and Colossus is
given his big speech about how you can
be a hero and when the music started
swallowing I was like he's going to kill
he's gonna shoot him in the head and
sure enough BAM mid-speech Colossus all
but just throws up his maybe life almost
was funny it's the weird little baby
hand like when Deadpool got his head
when he cut off his own hand it was
growing back but it was a weird little
baby hand
it's like twiddling the blind lady's
chin all right who didn't die laughing
and that saying is that [ __ ] was
hilarious and then the end credits scene
is funny we're all sitting around and I
was like here's how I would do an end
credits and I would have him come out
and be like oh you expected something
that's really funny now there's no end
credits in here go home and they kinda
did that but kind of did right when he
peaked out with the robe and his
Deadpool mask put the angle down the
hallway was like holy [ __ ] this is
Ferris Bueller everyone thought everyone
knew as Ferris Bueller he's like you're
still here it's over go home oh by the
way in the sequel we're totally getting
cable so just so you know I'm glad
they're getting cable because I'm taking
them at their word I believe they're
actually getting cable for the sequel
after something like that if they don't
have cable people are just gonna be
pissed so yeah it's totally gonna cable
any yeah this movie is totally gonna get
a sequel because it deserves what the
sequel I'm looking forward to more x-men
I mean things we see in x-men apocalypse
could play into Deadpool kind of maybe
even addresses like it's really funny
with such a huge mansion there's only
two people it's almost like the studio
couldn't afford more x-men but God
willing this movie's successful yeah
we're going to see a lot more of what we
loved in this movie this movie had what
it could have with the budget it could
have it with something like that it's
like this guy's I love Deadpool the more
you watch Deadpool the more you will
love it it is a perfect movie for the
movie they set out to make I really hope
you guys see this movie I hope it's the
success it deserves to be so Studios see
like oh wow okay you mean we can make
movies like that and they don't have to
be pg-13 fluff if they're supposed to be
rated on is a great statement for
my quick movies and I hope it does its
job well and I think it will alright
guys so again
Deadpool have you seen it what is your
favorite part of the movie whatever it
is comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to say more